okay hey second speaker today is your
father he is going to talk today about
dream grab differentially provide query
processing in private data Federation's
right thank you
but yeah so higher but no this is
working great so my name is Joe as Vader
I'm currently a PhD student Northwestern
University so I work mostly in databases
with a little bit on privacy and
security so this is gonna be a little
more like a systems focused talk we'll
be talking about a use case that we have
with Northwestern Hospital from the
system that we're building to enabled
some of them to do some of their their
analysis and help why and how we sort of
like introduced differential privacy
into everything and the benefits and the
negatives of that so first I want to say
thank you to my collaborator so there's
she who was a student at Duke who's now
a professor assistant professor at
University of Waterloo will who was the
master student who did a lot of the
grunt work of like bringing the
experiments and all that which is great
and he's now at Microsoft
Ashwin who actually was involved in the
last talk as well who's professor
Dubey's do we doing differential
products with databases for a long time
and of course my adviser Jenny Rogers
who's wonderful and of course I wouldn't
be here without her oh yeah so the time
of my talk is shrink-wrap differentially
private query processing in privately
owned Federation's
right and so that's a lot of words some
of them may may not make sense to you
but the goal for this talk today is
hopefully that will explain three things
first is what exactly is a private data
Federation how does the process queries
and why do we use differential privacy
this in a suggestive setting I mean the
woman I think that's that's the strength
that's the shrink-wrap icon I found like
I think does I couldn't find like I felt
like I couldn't use the actual
shrink-wrap it looks and trademark
issues but you see that that's like
shrink-wrap throughout this presentation
like address your mind oh yes sorry
it's not better that is rubbing against
okay how about
testing all right perfect great so a
little first just a little quick setup
so right so data is important there's a
lot of it
marching knowledge you can storm
processing no it's not the data we
couldn't do before and so there's a lot
of benefits and value now associate with
data the problem is that has to be its
fragments in amongst a that many
different owners and the problem this is
mostly because a lot of like security
and privacy issues right you can't just
have data all over the place so you know
in the news we see like Facebook Yahoo
uber all these issues with data breaches
and so people have really hesitant to
share the data because it has all this
bad right so one example of this is
gonna be medical data so medical data is
obviously it's very important that
maintain the privacy of the individuals
in the databases there's a lot of this
data that's that's all over the place so
an example here would be so this from
North Oaks we're working all close to
the hospital so example of one of the
schemas they have is they have something
like glucose measurement some sex and
diagnosis and so these have different
varying levels of privacy right so
glucose you can't really identify a
single person with that so that's more
of a public attribute versus the sector
or the actual diagnosis that's something
that's private because we could it's
personally identifiable right and so
something else they were trying to do
recently actually is create data
Federation's with all this medical data
and for example so you have all these
individual hospitals and they have all
this information they have so
bioinformatics asur data scientists
would go through and these medical
researchers would go through and try to
figure out like you know the incidences
of cancer with a co-worker with certain
other diseases and so the problem is
that they might have a very limited
amount of data it's only on the hospital
and they can't share this information
with other hospitals because of legal
requirements like hip-up which is like I
think the health and informations
protections Act of 96 yeah probably the
important bility I'm sorry but yeah so
there's all these legal issues where you
can't actually physically show us
information and so they weren't trying
to forget how to do this so they would
develop these things called kernel data
research networks right so these
some of healthcare sites that agree to
share data for research and so the idea
here is that by combining the data from
much of them hospitals we have a much
larger set of data that we can then use
to you know provide better research
queries and and help people right and so
for this project we part with health
link which is a Chicago based CD RN it's
run through Northwestern hospitals as
part of this overarching project called
Capricorn which is then associated with
this C Darin's across the entire country
and so they're trying to make this one
unified system where everything can be
executed and run right so the example
use case up here you have some sort of
client could be a medical researcher
they'd have some sort of question right
it was like how many diagnoses of some
rare disease X occurred and so what they
would do is they would translate that
into some sort of sequel query they
would send some coordinator who would
then send this query out to all the
different databases right and so these
are all gonna be sequel databases
setting somewhere in these hospital
systems and so these hospitals will
receive the Select query but the problem
is that now you're trying to access a
private attribute here and so in this
case you can't release this information
so you can't give the result in so the
client can no longer answer their query
is the problem so in talking to
Northwestern we sort of try to develop
an ideal solution here so we want what
they want is a database system that can
accurately evaluate queries in a
federated setting which is where all
these databases are physically separated
both have a common schema I want to
guarantee privacy is for individuals
whose data is in the dataset and we want
to process our queries efficiently right
so this is gonna be important
so we went through the literature and I
try to find some existing solutions so I
think the wrath of that you were saying
hey what if we just had a trusted third
party right what if we took all the data
Valentino's or innocent put them in a
single location so the problem with this
is that you can ensure privacy for
individuals because this single location
will have access to data from everybody
also you have some data breach issues
because you have a single point of
failure another option that people
worked with on is encrypted query
processing so the canonical example be a
crypt DB so they would use some forms of
like partial homomorphic encryption to
execute queries over this encrypted data
so the data will never be decrypted you
can just directly execute the queries
over this the issue with that is that
some of the techniques they were using
or about a little side channel attacks
such a frequent attacks cuz you were
leaking even though the data itself was
protected the access patterns were or
leaking with public information you
would know you could learn stuff about
the underlying data and there are there
has been some work and fully homomorphic
encryption which would solve some of
these issues but that is still much too
slow to work in practice right now
another option here is trusted execution
environment soldiers like that on ship
harbor enclaves
some lunch like base ID on your iPhone's
the problem is that there's no proper
meditation that actually works nothing I
used in X last year they are using
security last year they sort of showed
you breaking intel's version of SGX
which is our secure Enclave sort of on
live on stage which is very exciting but
also not so great for security ok so
these solutions internal work so then we
we were looking at differential privacy
right so we thought ok we can just add
some noise or clear their output of our
query results to protect underlying data
so this is sort of so much like the pink
approach so this is the status as
private is very efficient the problem
here is that wasn't the accuracy wasn't
wasn't there for us I'm solo Oh first
off the client was not receiving precise
results due to your adenoids that the
outputs and secondly certain queries
such as join queries on private
attributes you could just you just can't
answer them especially it was yours the
number of your clients scale and finally
your repeat
saying Dana will sort of consume your
budget over time and eventually that
data is unable to use right so it's okay
so a first pass will healthy
differential player but privacy maybe
not the ideal use so what we then then
did it was a look at secure multi-party
computation and so here what we are able
to allow us to securely compute
functions on data that are straight
across multiple data owners right so you
don't have a trusted third party here a
curious observer will learn nothing
about the data so this is will use this
some sort of improving cryptographic
protocols so like the canonical example
right is the millionaires problem as a
set up is where you have two
millionaires they have their something
net worth they want to compute a
function which is who's richer without
leak without revealing their private
data which is their net worth and so
there's garbled circuits um so yeah
garbled circuits are actually able to
evaluate that function that's securely
so this is accurate this is very this is
private the problem here is that it's
very inefficient so here it requires
something called rehearse oblivious
execution so yeah so basically we need
to eliminate all dependencies on
underlying data because if anything if
there's any dependency on it then you're
gonna be leaking information so it's
what this means that you have to obscure
all memory access patterns in program
execution
so all computation must say worst case
so for example all I could join all
joints will have to be a cross-product
you have to evaluate the entire cross
product in order to do this or a select
statement so if you would just you have
to sort of scan scan we have to filter
scan through the entire table instead of
just stopping if you're looking for a
certain element so that's so there's
some so there's some some great benefits
here but this inefficiency problem is is
kind of an issue but we felt like this
so this is like sort of a a list of all
our solutions all the approaches and the
current solutions into the literature
that we're looking at and so we're we've
said we decided that since nothing was
perfect we're gonna try to first focus
on accuracy and privacy and see if we
can maybe make some changes to make this
a little bit more efficient alright and
so our first attempt to a solution
something we call the privateer
Federation right so this is what this
in the title of the talk and so the
setup here is that given a public
relational database schema where data
owners all hold a horizontal partition
of the data in their own database so
that's not each Hospital has a
horizontal position of the data they all
have the same public schema right we all
be able provide a sequel query interface
for further clients so the medical
researchers we want provable secure
query evaluation over the union of these
databases so basically we want the the
the the researchers the query as if to
get results as if all the data was
stored on a single database and we wanna
provide accurate Korea's results so
precise query results and so we actually
went through and we built the system
actually published this in veal TV in
2017 so it was the first time you can
actually do an end-to-end system for
what sort of arbitrary sequel queries so
that was really exciting so here's like
if you remember the set up we had
earlier we had research work we had the
question right how many diagnosis of
rare disease X occurred they change like
test sequel queries and this is some
coordinator who then passes that
information out to the different
databases right and now instead of just
saying hey this is a private attribute
we can't use now we can actually use the
secure multi-party computation and so we
can use this computation across each
other get a share of the results so it's
gonna be encrypted and then pass that
back to the coordinator who then passes
who then combines all the information
and the reconstructs the it's the final
answer and so the client gets the court
plaintext resolved yes
this looks too good to be true is there
a restriction of what kind of secret
queries can be used so it took a while
to actually implement so we actually
implement these in like a with the
secure multi-party confrontation
language but yeah so we can we support
most pretty much every all the basic
ones like filters scans joins and
aggregates okay so yeah so you exactly
so there's no free lunch right so it's
it sounds great it's perfect but the
problem is that your there's a huge
performance issue right because you're
running everything in the worst case
so all joins are N squared and awesome
you get to joins you're going into the
end cubed and you know this is huge
explosion and so we actually well
actually ran these on some some medical
research or workloads we're getting
things like you know four to six orders
of magnitude star yes is there a
breakdown how much of that is
communication between parties versus
yeah so that actually came in this case
the communication costs were very low
relatively speaking so most of that was
and then bill via SRAM was so every time
you do a memory access you have to touch
every single piece of data in the entire
because I think in the previous
presentation where yes you can leaked
information based on access patterns yes
a week we added dummy values into them
so so we're doing I can show an example
here maybe I'm asking like something
from drop glass Oh
so at this point we're not using
differential privacy at all all right so
this is just a purely secure multi-party
computation so this is there's no
privacy budget there's no noise or
anything that we're getting precise
query results at the output it's just
that it's extremely extremely slow so
this is like experiments where
computation rights been like theoretical
for a long time it just only recently
has been able to you know be something
that's sort of reasonably usable yes so
could you explain a little bit white oh
it's not okay why hospitals aren't
comfortable releasing an aggregate like
the example you had it was a count of
people that diagnosis X they're not
comfortable releasing that number even
though it's an aggregate it's not an
individual row level piece of data but
they are comfortable with eventually the
aggregate when it's combined with say
two other hospitals with that becoming
public right so you're okay yeah so
let's see here
well so what you're asking why they all
come from releasing this result of this
query instead of the ones individually
from using these databases for that's
that's kind of interesting I think they
prefer alongside they were using K on
MIDI as their sort of privacy guarantee
and so I think as a result of that so
for now they're saying that we can trust
the client in some ways but not gonna
sort of release this data into the wild
but still like these individual
hospitals they can't know what's on each
individual hospice or so that sort of
your it's like it's from some Hospital
we don't know exactly what it is this
it's it's not like super formal but
that's that's kind of how they do it
yeah any other questions okay right so
this is the performance problem and so
this is what we were struggling left to
try to to try to fix because four to six
orders of magnitude I was sitting there
running queries for like several days
which was at the beginning my PhD was
great cuz I got it like I was able to
catch up on all on Netflix so just I was
a hit play and I just could kind of
watch TV shows
unfortunately that gravy train was ended
so now they had to speed these things up
and I was I'm now very far behind on my
TV and so explain to you how that
happens all right so now what can I go
into so the media talked over talked
about how we applied differential
privacy in this setting so first let's
talk about the performance bottle now to
give you intuition about why it's so
slow then I'll talk about a couple of
technical contributions and then I'm
going to go into the shrink-wrap great
processing
set up talk about how we're using
differentially private resizing which is
for the key element here then talk about
sort of a cost model as
personally I love cost models so we'll
talk about that a bit how we use that
cost mile to split our privacy budget
throughout our execution and finally go
over some actual experimental results
using real real data okay great
so this is just like a typical query
tree so you have your you know sequel
query up there
and then you have this is a
representation of different operators
right you have your filters join join
and then aggregate on top and here in
the little brackets are going to be the
sizes of those the number of tuples
they're the size of the output of each
of these so that there's n tuples in
this medication table and tuples in
diagnosis table and this is this is I'm
showing you this is the worst case
scenario right so why I mentioned
earlier we can't assume that anything
has been filtered out right so at every
point we have that to access and tuples
we have to run this filter on n tuples
we have to run this joint on instant and
squared tuples on n cubed tuples and so
on alright and so this is really really
expensive and the reason is how we have
this we're adding padding here to
protect this data because if this was
something less than N squared then you
wouldn't learn something you'll be
leaking some information about that data
right and when you leak information if
you like run enough times then you'll be
able to learn to actually good useful
daughter line data is right and so then
that's this is what caused this
exponential blow-up and it's really
really expensive okay so now we're gonna
go into some of the technical
contributions here we have at first we
had a computational differential privacy
mechanism this is two intermittent
upstart go ahead question so in that you
want to have secure computation we
forces you to hide those numbers but at
the end you're gonna release the number
of rows at the root yeah
so we yeah so the output so so yes so
our work is mostly focused on matron
we're not releasing any information
during execution and so there is the
issue it's like the actual answer to the
query is going to be some eight some
information about the data and so for
that we'll have to we sort of say that
you know this is something that you have
to handle with access pattern control or
you could actually use differential
privacy as well right so yeah and I have
a table in a little bit to talk about
the trust model exactly but yes that's
that's a great point this is just purely
for execution so right and that's I
think was actually kind of really
interesting work is we're playing
differential privacy not just that the
output would actually during execution
to speak without right okay so yeah so
we have a sort of computational privacy
mechanism so the minimizes intermediate
result padding right so we want to make
this keep this and make this something
smaller than N squared and as you know
as it goes through we'll see that that
benefits as it goes off the tree so
that'll speed up for query processing a
second when I do some sort of we don't
have a protocol agnostic architecture
because you notice constantly new
research I'm gonna be able to plug and
play different SMC I'm sorry secure
multi-party computation in protocols
actually in the process of writing this
the initially the we had two different
port a new protocol was released it was
actually three orders of magnitude
faster than the one we were originally
using so that was so it was very
important for us to be able to have cost
model that was general enough to handle
all of this and so something that we
could use to estimate our secure
computation costs and once we have that
secure estimation cost estimates we
actually can apply a budget splitting
algorithm right because we're applying
our privacy budget during execution and
so it's not entirely clear off right off
the bat like how should we split it up
at each of these operators right there's
a couple of pit strategies I'll go into
later and provide some experimental
results to show but yeah so what we
actually doing was we have this cost
mountain we sort of up the tree does
optimization
to figure out where we can apply
differential privacy to maximize the
benefit right because it's a really
valuable thing you don't want just you
know spread it all over an inefficient
way cool so yes this is the end-to-end
shrink-wrap query processing right so
you have a client you have a
coordinating our data owners and what it
starts out with again we're just about
the core what the client doesn't takes
she takes a query and a privacy budget
sends that to a coordinator the coroner
will then generate a private query plan
which is gonna be based on SMC and some
sort of budget allocation a pass that
see the data owners and then the data
owner each individually compute the
query plan get some sort of getting the
encrypted results send that back to the
to the coordinator within assembles all
these shares of these results and gives
an unencrypted result back to the client
so yeah this is the overall end to end
and we'll kind of go into where each of
these you see this little shrink app
icon we're gonna go in and go in a
little bit more detail
all right so first I want to talk about
is our trust model there's our privacy
goals and our assumptions here so it's a
lot of text so sorry about that
but here we'll try to simplify it so
there's we have two alpha policies one
is where the client sees these true
exact answers right and so we don't we
already say like you know we're not
going to worry about the privacy of
these output results or with our leaking
that's going something that's based on
access control but we also have the
second policy where we say we actually
have noisy and noisy results so this is
where we actually using differential
privacy so to handle the information
leakage right and so we have our data
owners right in our clients so in this
case we actually treat the corn and the
client as you know as a corn is an
extension of the clients right and so
the privacy goals for data owners is
that they have a differential private
view over data held by other data owners
right and so this is where a hospital
can't see the to not have access to the
private data of another hospital right
so they have a differential private view
for the client in the first policy we've
said the client only wants a query
answer and the second one is you know
the client would have a different
surprise view of the data held by these
data owners we assume that you know
there's a semi honest so everybody will
follow the protocol honestly but they
will are curious and they will like sort
of try to look at the execution try to
learn stuff about the data and find
where something everybody's
computationally bounded that's the
reason computational differential
privacy here and in here when when
you're saying true answers we assume
that there's no collusion between data
or sort of clients but when you have
difference of private out we can you
know you can allow them to conclude as
much they want cool so yes this is our
truck our privacy goals and assumptions
so yeah so again we're going back here
we show this is what we're trying to fix
right this N squared n cube turns here
how should I think about these two
columns is this do they exist in
parallel are you making a decision to be
moved from one to the other depending on
what the client does yeah so in the way
we built a system you can it's up to
whoever I guess the DBA of deep database
admin an administrator to say we're
releasing true results are releasing
noisy answers and yeah and so that's
that's something you're not so you
shouldn't be flipping back and forth
between these within decline or what so
this is so the client may be this might
not explaining it so that yeah so here
so this this Archer right here is this
going to be the true plaintext result of
this query Q or is it going to be a
noisy our right and so we handle both of
these situations they say like if if if
the database administrator decides hey
we're gonna release this exact true R
then these are the assumptions that
we'll have and if they decide now we're
actually releasing annoys aversion and
these are the assumptions that we'll
have hopefully that okay yes first of
all should they think about this as a
multi-party computation protocol that
has leakage but the leakage is
eventually private yes yeah so yeah
let's see if I can do okay so these ends
are going to be comfortable yeah okay
yeah so normally you wouldn't have any
leakage here right so this is it all
it's completely padded no leakage but
what I say is we actually make this a
differential private size and so that
will not leak information and so the
intuition here is that like what we
saying is that like you know fully
private are fully secured is too
expensive and so can we selectively
leaked a little bit information and get
a huge performance gain right and then
and we're using differential wireless
privacy to figure out okay well how can
we bound this information leakage
as emotes the whole thing is about
privacy versus performance
yes apartment any questions about this
right yes so Frank it really is N
squared n cubed terms and so we here as
we have this differential private
resizing so this will be an example so
let's take an example a little bit join
so we're joining two tables are NS and
in the plain text version we would just
have is that this would be the result of
this right this is just I know whatever
the size of the output is here in the
oblivious version we have exhausted
panic so this would be n size n square
right so this would be you know whatever
the size of our times the size of this
so this is very expensive to and then
and secure multiple smc we'd have to you
know process this entire thing here but
what we did in shrink wrap actually was
we say okay well what if we now have a
difference of private size so what we do
is we take if our new size is going to
be what the true cardinality is what
this true real data is plus and more
plasmus we're here we use is we did
one-sided we did a truncated applause as
we have one side of noise because we
didn't want to eliminate any of the the
totals in here so it's just only
positive noise what so with high
probability we don't we don't drop it in
tuples and so the actual algorithm right
is we have we have all this data it's
going to be sort of real data and dummy
data sort of mix together so the first
thing I have to do is a bluesy sort it
so it looks like this nice real data
here on one side like array that we did
at the end of the array then we
calculate the one-sided
DP noise so we figure out okay what's
this size and then we create so we
create this new array this will be an
empty array of this new differentially
private size and then we just copy over
data you know from here to here so now
we'll have this new array that has all
the real data as well as some done with
you know yes
generate the opossum out yeah so we'll
happen
we'll have to do all the N squared first
just because it's for a couple reasons
hold one is like it's not all it's not
nice and neat like this it's kind of
like all dispersed through initially
yeah so that's this kind of manner so
yeah we can't we can't do that right
away we have to actually go through and
execute it first and then we decrease it
right so it's it's that makes it
interesting because the benefit you see
is actually so the benefit is so this is
still expensive but now this is now
cheaper because the output the inputs of
this new op next operator is smaller
[Applause]
yeah so okay that makes sense is how
this works so you can see this we're
gonna apply to see all the different
operators and so we're get same Toby mob
much cheaper to execute and so we
actually have a we had created a cost
model here for how expensive this is
basically it's like the the size of
these things and so we have we first
have well the cost of the actually
employing the operator so actually if
I'm gonna join they don't have the cost
of the sorting and the cost of the
copying here all right
and so one note is that we actually have
to use cardinality estimates and this
was not going to be totally optimal
because you know we can we don't know
the true output cardinalities here we
don't know the output carnatic you until
we actually run the query and if we run
the query that we're gonna be paying
that cost so we use some traditional
really naive database cardinality
estimates to figure out you know it's
asking me what it is so this is sort of
a it's kind of a weakness in here so so
that's where we may be missing out a lot
of optimization opportunities because
we're just guessing what it is
we action will show later on that I
should have to make so much less such a
difference practically yeah so this is
our model for how much how expensive
this execution is and so once we have
that cost model what we don't we use
that to figure out how we split our
privacy budget so we read sure right as
an optimization problem so
minimize the cost such that you know
epsilon and Delta's add up to whatever
the the totals are so total execution
privacy budget and so we want to solve
for these epsilon eyes and Delta eyes to
figure out what the privacy budget at
each operator is right and so hopefully
this will be not purely not a true
optimal but like something that's
something that's better than just a
naive budget split okay so going back
now we can sort of see like all this
this picture makes a little bit more
sense now you can see yeah we're how we
get a privacy budget how we allocate
this privacy budget and how we actually
do the differential private resizing
okay great so now let's go on to some
experimental results right so this is
systems guys so like you know having
some numbers so what we did we actually
got some data from Northwestern
hospitals from this health linked data
repository we were access to we actually
actually have more years but we actually
we chose you via one year Chicago area
hospital we use 2006 which is about 15
gigabytes of data and then I scaled it
up with synthetic data up to about you
know 750 gigabytes and then weaves a
couple different ran my little circuit
model um
secure SMC and unless otherwise state
so we reported these results do you
think we would put average execution
times he's an epsilon about 0.5 and a
delta of 5 to the negative fifth one
note is that it was like really
difficult getting all this data because
because of all these like security and
privacy concerns it actually took me I
want to say about six months to get
access to everything because I had like
I've put the application in and they
have to approve it to the IRB and then
have to Beit make you go in and take
like a sequel test and do everything so
that's the problem we're trying to solve
is is actually getting this to work so
this is actually actually working on a
different project and we ran through
these issues and like okay this is a
problem that we should really be trying
to solve first before we can move on to
anything else and so yeah so it actually
worked out really well there are
partners at Northwest Hospital were able
to give us all this information
so yeah and this including we actually
had access to their medical researchers
so they actually give us like the real
words that they were using in practice
and so these are three examples one was
a docent study are talking about
comorbidity aspirin count and this is
actually a synthetic query that I
generated based off of other workload so
you can see they're kind of complex but
um some have a lot of joins somewhere
like sort of counting queries just sort
of a mix so first off is going to be
talking Maya's end-to-end performance
here so both with and without shrink
wrap so without shrink wrap is just the
pure SMC case and in which shrink wrap
is going to be with our difference
reprieve of sizes so these are on the
bottom are gonna be listing a couple
different queries for a workload and
then with two different SMC protocols so
you can see actually it's sort of
dependent on the type of query to see
what how much of a speed up you get dish
but we did we do show that you know so
this circuit model is Clos it's a E&P
library I was out of University of
Maryland so this came out while we're
writing the paper and it was like pretty
incredible we got actually have 3x
speed-up over the original model over
here model we were using but for in both
cases we're actually still still able to
show about up to about three orders of
magnitude improvement just by using
differential privacy five minutes
perfect go quickly through these then
and then the next experiments we did
with sort of figure out like how these
trade-offs of privacy accuracy and
performance so the first one was just
you know as we vary the privacy budget
how is their performance change right
and you can sort of see as you expect as
you increase the privacy budget you're
getting you know less there's less
privacy for the individuals in the
database but you're getting much better
performance second as we talked about
sort of action suit performance so set
up for this is that we have this is in
the second model where we have a
difference we private output so we have
a we have a single privacy budget but we
have two places where we can use it both
at once at the output and once in the
exoteric execution so it's like figure
out okay well if I apply more during
execution or more than at the output so
if we apply
more during execution that means we have
a smaller budget to use at the output so
our actually goes down but our
performance because we use more during
execution our performance goes up and we
actually see that the benefits of this
sort of tail off as you get using sarees
you sort of tail off because if you're
applying more privacy budget during
execution you still have a limit of just
like actually you know what the what the
tables look like what the day that looks
like and so there's like a point where
it you you get diminishing returns next
we looked at budget splitting strategies
so we remember I talked about a cost
model and the splitted splitting to
figure out like how we do things so
there's the naive case right if you just
uniformly split the budget across all
the operators
there's the eager case where you spend
your entire budget on your first
operator and assume that because these
the benefits that will cascade
throughout the rest of the query then we
did an optimum when we using our actual
cost model and then finally compare it
to an Oracle which was using the actual
true cardinality instead of estimated
cardinalities and you can kind of see
here that in all cases the Oracle
perform best as you it expects and then
the optimal but the often was actually
very close right so only you know within
not well then like you know thirty three
exit 34 X it's not such a huge
difference and you can see that like
yeah if we just applied uniformly to be
good at some queries but not others over
the eager missionary vice versa so
there's just to prove that you know the
cost modeling and bunch of splitting was
actually useful and was something that
was worthwhile doing finally one we want
to also show so how we sort of scale
with more complex queries right and so
maybe we show like you know if there's
ones we use joins as a model as a
shorthand for how complex the quarry is
as a number of joins increase the the
more speed-up we actually got and that
sort of makes sense because you know
we're we're you get the sort of
cascading benefit so that
next we want to scale up data size so as
we Inc we use for this one use synthetic
data and so as you know increase it that
they decides like how does that affect
the performance here and we saw that
sort of as we had more data we had more
speed up because you know you're getting
more and more dummy values but it was
nice this is this is the fun experiments
I run actually oh yeah and so that's
those are kind of the results that we
have here through our experiments and
there's a couple open problems that
we're still sort of working through with
our partners one is through how can we
use privacy budget usage for large court
workloads there's a little bit of work
right with like HD mmm and things where
you can sort of combine all your
workloads and you know minimize the
amount of privacy budget are you using
but there's we focused there's probably
some better ways to do that you know I
think we can also sort of find better
bounds on our privacy losses for each
operator right now we're sort of doing a
really simple ways of doing it but I
think there's some things with maybe
adopted composition and things like that
we can be kind of getting we can get
better better bounds so we use less
privacy each operator and finally you
know sort of dealing with or not dealing
with but I provide providing results to
our users actually explain like how can
we use the furniture privacy and and
what does it actually mean to them it
has been it's been interesting so the
cool part about actually this project is
that even if we run out of broad privacy
budget we can still provide results they
took users right so in this case we
because we don't want to use up our
budget right away this we sort of use
differential privacy more like sort of
an accelerator for from when like
there's a query that's really important
we want them to to apply it and so we
have to figure out like how can we show
users like when to apply different
privacy should we just do this
automatically for them sort of this is
all these thing you know sort of user
interfacing so we're doing with as well
but yep so just to conclude I want to
say that we go we did that we create a
protocol agnostic query processing for
private data Federation's we create a
cost model to optimize the privacy
budget users across our operators and
you know difference right we also
provide different surprises guarantee
that trade-off privacy for significant
performance improvements so yeah so
here's hopefully this talk I was able to
answer you know you're able to answer
these two questions about you know what
is the private data Federation how's the
process queries and of course you know
why is differential privacy important in
this situation yeah so thank you very
much questions yes can you comment on
the how you exploit the assumption that
the data is horizontally partitioned and
maybe give an example of yeah sure where
each Hospital can just compute locally
everything and then only do one addition
at the top yeah so a horizontal
partition right so that means that
everybody has the same schema that's is
public but they each have you know some
set of there's some disjoint data that
within that right
and so yeah there we did do some
optimizations actually as if we knew
that you know some data for some patient
was only on one Hospital then they would
be only ones that can actually execute
that and it didn't have to involve the
other parties is that answering your
question looking at this setting
intuitively it looks like every for
meaningful queries every hospital could
just run the query
because queries are going to be like how
many patients certain condition Oh
so yeah just run them locally on each of
them and yes that's true so there's that
it's not of these forms yeah so here we
have this workload so for here so it's
mostly comes in when we need to join
across different databases so so the
example would be like for a lot of times
like patients will we go into different
hospitals right so they'll go to one
hospital but then they'll you know for
another treatment I'll go to a different
one right and so the hospitals don't
have access to that data so they want to
join so like their initial diagnosis
they got at hospital a but later the
treatment they got was hospital B
and so like that the researcher wants to
know like you know how did the treatment
perform are like compared to in hostel a
versus hostel be Oreo this diagnosis
time but you know possible he doesn't
have access to that information
oh yeah sorry no the ha those patients
are could be sped across um it's
different it's actually really important
because like you know things like feel
like such like vulnerable populations
they typically don't have like one
hospital they always go to but yes the
private version the table that you had
oh yes so you could do this kind of
analysis in the setting where the Klein
can only access the differentiation yeah
so for I think will for these you could
do that so like what do they have a
output those account you can instead of
outputting the true count you could have
a noise account right yeah I'm talking
about like wait this example that you
had like you're trying to basically
create a new record that has data from
several hospital how would you do that
is the time I don't understand you have
a patient who has a diagnosis in one yes
and then a treatment in a yes in how
could you then think so you do a joint
of these yeah
it in your differentiate private city
how could you do that successful so the
initial all the comp initial computation
is going to be still be done and using
secure mount SMC secured most by
computation and so the way that actually
works is that when we do this initially
so everybody each of the parties in the
competition is gonna be executing this
query and so before we when we first
start we have to do a union across all
the databases together and they create
the secret share of the total of all the
results and each hospital will give a
share of that so each hospital have sort
of access to an encrypted version of the
union of all the databases and then they
can then they can use SMC to do all this
computation what they want makes it I
mean awesome so the client doesn't see
that I'm trying to think from a
perspective of the researcher yes what
would she see the noisy with no bad at
the end yeah she would only see that out
the final output and so most of the
essence see and that's gonna be guarding
the data owners from each other so like
hospital a from hospital P because
they're honest a curious so that they
they will follow the protocol but
they'll still like sort of kicad
execution right
okay so a this thing do they speak it
again this we reconvene and